so one of the things that fascinates me
most about these Halloween mazes is just
what it takes to actually make them
happen the casting process the rules all
the behind the scenes detail so in
making this movie is there anything you
learned about that process that really
surprised you the scare performers make
the maze we were lucky enough to have
performers that had appeared at mazes
throughout Atlanta they're amazing
actors and they sell it they're great
they're there's a certain language they
all have to it and I thought it really
gave an authenticity to the film
absolutely I mean it's something that
you can't train someone overnight and
and they were more experienced than we
were yes in pulling this off it's always
great to surround yourself with
incredibly talented performers and
another thing you guys include in this
movie that I'm fascinated by is the idea
of taking it a step further and signing
the waiver and giving characters the
ability to touch you there are a lot of
more extreme things that aren't in the
movie so in making this is there
anything you considered putting in that
made you think alright I think we're
taking it too far now I think we I think
we we have should we be so lucky that
audiences love this and we make a sequel
we have a few tricks up our sleeve so
we're gonna save it for that I like the
sound of that
out of curiosity without spoiling
anything this movie feels like it could
be the start of a really great anthology
series to me is that something that
might be in the back of your minds right
now a hundred percent I don't know we
definitely have I sort of a mythology
for prequel as well as sequel and
definitely character you know this
character or the other we really want to
explore and I want to bring Tony Todd
back million percent is amazing another
thing speaking of Tony Todd that comes
up a lot in this movie especially as a
hardcore slasher fan there are so many
little nods to qualities in those movies
that I absolutely love was it tough for
you to kind of keep the iconic slashers
out of it yes and no cuz this is a bit
of a love letter to the slashers that I
grew up on so I have no problem paying
homage to all those great films that we
bonded on it we were developing the the
the project so I think it's okay to pay
respects to what came before us and try
to move ahead and recreate the slashers
another thing that I really wanted to
ask you about with the process of making
this kind of movie is the test screening
process also because with slasher campy
slasher movies you want to hit that
right balance between real terror but
also having an entertaining fun ride and
I think you do that well here so did you
have a test screening and what you learn
from it we had a test screening and we
found that the horror fans loved it the
horror fans the true horror fans it hit
him right where we're supposed to hit
and great thing was the non horror fans
that were there responded well they
liked the characters they liked the
story they liked the tension so it's a
really successful screening and we
learned that it's okay to give the
people what they want so there's some
times you know you want to water down go
pg-13 but we learned is our was good and
give them what they want and but give
them most importantly what we wanted to
do which was make a good fun slasher
it's a great ride and you can bring
people who may wonder if this movies for
them and I think they'll find something
to like going to see it too I also
wanted to highlight a little bit of your
cast here and just the idea of you know
chemistry you're eating and assembling
the right group what was that process
like for you and how'd you land on your
leads
we had great casting directors both in
Atlanta and Los Angeles and we we cast
the girls first and the great revelation
was each girl that came in fit the roles
Amy who plays Natalie and then rain came
in for Brooke and the big revelation for
me initially was the Taylor character
was was in my mind somebody else but
when Beck's came in there was no other
Taylor for me she just became the role
and all three girls when we got him in
the room together were just phenomenal
and the film is so much for me about the
the power that these girls have these
women have and if they don't need the
guys to come save the day and Ripley was
always a huge character for me and we
had talked about this and I really
wanted this to be about female
empowerment and
and these women are all strong smart and
they just fit well and then the guys
when we when we cast them again as soon
as they all got in the room together
they were best friends and all six with
what I got together like you'd think
they'd know each other forever so it was
just really one of those serendipitous
moments that they all just came together
and it's really fun because Becks
actually comes from Atlanta and everyone
would go over to her parents house and
hang out the best so you know that's a
choice you don't have to hang out after
work but when you choose to you know
you've got a great chemistry among the
cast that on the screen we just made we
just made a dinner that was from one of
exes grandmother's recipes and it's
gonna be like one of our recipes for
that for the rest of our lives so it's
great a lot of family Halloween is right
around the corner now so I'm curious do
you guys have any Halloween traditions
or special plans well my birthday is
right before Halloween so is mine we're
Halloween babies so you know it's my
favorite holiday 100% my - I'm the day
before Halloween so I this whole month
is essentially a big Halloween party
dress up I have kids there they're into
it so it's great Thanksgiving baby I
feel like I was meant to be born around
time though
[Music]